[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight smallpox the bubonic
plague the Spanish flu those are some of
the many diseases that have changed the
course of history over the last few
thousand years here's a new one bound
for the DSM Trump derangement syndrome
it's particularly insidious illness
because it doesn't merely affect
individuals but entire political parties
rendering them unrecognizable until
about 20 minutes ago for example the
Democrats saw themselves as the party of
reason resistant to superstition and
mass hysteria they were as they often
told you the party that fought
McCarthyism now it's the party that
engages in McCarthyism enthusiastically
watch this was nothing short of
treasonous because it is a betrayal of
the nation he is giving aid and comfort
to the enemy I think Donald Trump is a
fascist I think everything he stands for
is disgusting
that is pure racism and the president is
cynically using that racism to appeal to
his base that is not what you've seen a
democracy that is exactly what you see
in authoritarian regimes speaking of
hysteria Maxine Waters of course did not
stop there she urged her followers to
hunt down and harass anybody tied to the
Trump administration
[Music]
oh and they obeyed and as a result this
happened this is all rage by proxy of
course they'd like to hurt Trump himself
but he's not around so they attack his
employees and supporters and in the
absence of any of those a star on the
sidewalk with his name on it watch this
that's how it started but smashing the
star did not cool the emotions of the
star smashers now the star is a venue
for street fights
hear that what you haven't heard our
Democratic leaders appealing for calm
the Democratic Party at this point has
become totally unwarranted to find it
under Franklin Roosevelt Democrats
champion working Americans in organized
labor they couldn't do that today too
many union members or middle-aged white
guys instead their only remaining
principle is hatred of the president if
Trump supports something they're against
it if he's against it they're huge fans
no matter what it is consider the events
of the past few months ms their team for
example a deadly street gang that
engages in sex trafficking rape drug
smuggling torture murder with knives and
mr. team preys on poor people mostly
immigrants the president called them
animals because they are within hours
the left produced a wave of speeches and
op-eds extolling the basic human dignity
of gang members with face tattoos whose
model is kill rape control once they
embraced ms-13 the left decided that the
law enforcement agency charged with
arresting ms-13 must be bad hence the
now common demand that ice be abolished
so that immigration laws can never again
be enforced and then there's stormy
Daniels even on the far left hardcore
pornography was not considered an ideal
career for your daughter
and then Daniel's and her creepy Cable
friendly lawyer emerged and now Daniels
is touted on the left is some sort of
civil rights hero when Rudy Giuliani
doubted her credibility he was blasted
for impugning the respectability of
women who have sex with strangers on
camera for pay well for years the left
was even more adamant than the right in
demanding free speech for Americans and
good for them and then came Trump free
speech allowed Donald Trump and his
supporters to be heard so now the left
is against free speech they're begging
Facebook and Twitter to suppress the
opinions they dislike and censor news
outlets that don't tow the new
democratic party line the line that has
existed for about 15 minutes left also
used to worry about the unchecked power
of the most powerful sectors of our
government the CIA in the FBI and the
whole constellation of alphabet agencies
they worried that those bureaucrats
might violate civil liberties at will
they might spy on Americans so they
might hide all of that beneath the black
cloak of the word classified now those
agencies have used their power to spy on
from associates and leak damaging
information
about the administration to the press
suddenly the left considers them these
unaccountable members of the deep state
heroes how about this one
for decades the left accused the rich of
not paying their fair share of taxes
okay last year's tax reform bill rolled
back the amount of state and local taxes
rich people can deduct now that the
wealthy though formed the core of the
Democratic Party's constituency liberals
are outraged by this New York and New
Jersey are suing the Trump
administration to get the rich their tax
deductions back we could go on and on
and on george w bush embroiled america
in a ruinous middle eastern war the left
hated him for that now he gave a speech
criticizing Trump last year so he's
fully rehabilitated the left used to
fear corporate control of major news
outlets and they should but after
President Trump attacked the Washington
Post as a mouthpiece for Amazon mogul
Jeff Bezos a USA Today columnist said
those critiques were quote attacks on
the First Amendment as if they defend
the First Amendment they don't President
Trump tweeted threats at Kim jong-un so
his sister was praised at the Winter
Olympics for stealing the spotlight from
vice president pence
she must be great the president hates
her brother president Trump wants better
relations with Russia and peace in Syria
so naturally all the geniuses in
Washington tell us we have to prepare
for war against both countries so anyone
who remembers the Democrats of the 1960s
the 90s or even three years ago it's all
very confusing that party is dead it's
been replaced by a new one whose entire
platform could be say no to trump this
isn't politics anymore it's the world's
dumbest religion